une semaine maintenant la disparition et
la mort de Justine 20 ans après une
soirée en boîte de nuit et me toute la
France la jeune maman aurait été tué
enterrée par Lucas 20 ans aussi 20 ans
aussi d'ailleurs qui a reconnu le
meurtre pourtant il reste encore de
nombreuses zones d'ombre alors que des
proches et des témoins commencent à
parler l'autopsie vient d'être rendu
public et il y a des nouvelles infos sur
ce drame Michel Marie sera avec nous
dans un instant regarde
après une sortie en boîte de nuit le
weekend dernier Justine est assassiné un
ouvrier agricole de 21 ans est alors
placé en garde à vue et confie l'avoir
tué puis enterré dans les bois il a
précisé sans donner davantage
d'explications qui lui avait donné un
coup de poing ce qui occasionné le décès
et aujourd'hui les premiers éléments de
l'autopsie de la jeune femme ont été
révélés on en sait un petit peu plus sur
les conditions de sa
mort-elle les propos du meurtrier
présumé Michel Marie est avec nous ce
soir pour toutes les dernières
révélations
nous sommes donc avec Michel marie
journaliste nouveau détective merci
d'être là Michel et on a eu de nouvelles
révélations
l'autopsie de la jeune fille doit donc
été révélée
alors le top 6 est quelque chose de très
important dans une enquête criminelle
c'est même quelque chose de fondamental
d'autant qu'on a un auteur se présumé
Julien
Lucas pardon
qui a fait des aveux
mais des aveux partiels rien de colle
finalement par rapport à tout ce qui
raconte ou en tout cas pas grand chose
et maintenant
l'autopsie va permettre de remettre un
petit peu les choses en perspective et
les choses en place alors c'est un peu
technique mais c'est très important
qu'est-ce qu'on apprend par le top 6 on
peut avoir l'heure de la mort la
datation de la mort donc la cause de la
mort
et puis s'il y a eu des violences qui
n'ont pas forcément entraîné la mort
mais qui sont hantée mortem ou
accessoirement post mortel et là on a
appris aujourd'hui ce que l'on sait
c'est qu'elle est morte étranglée
et le fait qu'elle soit morte étranglée
ça va ça va à l'encontre de ce qu'il a
déclaré lui qu'est-ce qui déclare il
déclare qu'il
emmené chez lui dans la nuit
qu'ils ont eu une relation intime et
qu'à un moment donné une relation intime
consentie et qu'à un moment donné il lui
a donné un coup de poing alors déjà
avant même l'autopsie a eu un à la levée
de corps et un médecin qui examine le
corps qui dit mais il y a pas eu un coup
il y en a eu plusieurs dont notamment
avec une arme lourde un marteau une
massue ou quelque chose de dur donc déjà
ça ça va pas
et puis il y a aucun moment il ne parle
d'étranglement donc ça vient
complètement contredire sa contredit
complètement ce qu'il a déclaré lors de
sa garde à vue
la chose importante en revanche pendant
la garde à vue c'est qu'il amène les
enquêteurs sur le lieu de sépultures
c'est à l'endroit où il a enterré cette
malheureuse jeune fille et ça même s'il
revient à un moment donné sur ses aveux
ça restera c'est il y a que lui qui
pouvait emmener les enquêteurs à cet
endroit le produit le procureur avait un
temps parlé d'une arme contondante qu'on
utilise écoutez ça reste d'actualité
sauf que on ne sait pas de quoi il
s'agit est-ce que c'est un marteau
est-ce que c'est un rouleau à pâtisserie
est-ce que c'est une batte de baseball
en fait on en sait rien est-ce qu'on
sait un peu plus sur ce qui serait ce
serait passé lors de cette fameuse nuit
avant qu'elle ne quitte la boîte de nuit
ou après après si vous voulez on a
encore là j'en ai pas parlé le problème
de d'une éventuelle prise de drogue
prise à son insu bien évidemment
on se souvient qu'elle a dit à son à son
copain Théo je crois très bien puisqu'on
a le témoignage
elle avait envie de vomir elle avait
besoin de prendre l'air elle est sortie
et c'est à ce moment-là qu'intervient le
suspect numéro un dans cette histoire
celui qui est mis en examen et on a
parlé différents témoignages on comprend
comment les choses se sont articulées
l'autopsie devrait permettre aussi de
révéler s'il y a eu ou non prise de
d'une drogue de la part de cette jeune
fille
le GHB c'est très volatil ça reste pas
longtemps dans l'organisme mais on a
peut-être une chance de retrouver quand
même à la fois dans Ça c'est le problème
de la Napat mais ou dans le sang ou dans
les urines on peut retrouver ou dans les
cheveux évidemment les zones c'est le
mobile aussi le mobile il me semble
quand même en filigrane à peu près
établi ce serait bah ça serait une
une histoire sexuelle enfin
moi ce qui me choque dans ce dossier
c'est
il dit j'ai eu un rapport consenti nous
avons eu un rapport consenti et tout de
suite après il la frappe violemment
d'où ça sort en général quand les gens
ont des rapports
intimes entre eux ils se mettent pas des
coups de matraque sur la tête donc je
pense que le problème il tourne autour
de ça si vous voulez
pourquoi il sait c'est ça et donc est-ce
qu'on a l'horaire de la mort je suis mal
moi je l'ai pas mais j'ai envie de vous
dire que ça a pas une très grande
importance on sait qu'elle est à peu
près à quelle heure elle est partie de
la boîte de nuit avec enfin en tout cas
on sait à quel moment Théo la laisse en
tête-à-tête avec
avec
ça et donc là on a on a l'horaire
ensuite il y a le délai de route
j'ignore la distance
je sais que moi j'ai une équipe au
nouveau détective qui a refait tout le
chemin
et donc mais c'est c'est en cours en
fait c'est ça sera avant de bientôt
mais bon l'horaire dans cette affaire me
semble pas très importante si vous
voulez on sait qu'elle est partie avec
ce garçon on sait que Théo l'a eu au
téléphone à un moment donné je crois
vers 4h du matin quelque chose comme ça
ou il
il lui parle et il dit
je vous en prie il lui parle
il y a des dossiers si vous voulez ou
l'horaire de la mort est important par
rapport à la Libye mais là oui là en
l'occurrence à 10 minutes près même à
une heure près ça n'a aucune importance
merci en tout cas Michel Marie parce que
c'est vrai qu'ils ont des infos tous les
jours sur ce dossier Gilles très
important effectivement dans l'analyse
toxicologique s'il y a eu administration
de drogue ça va vouloir dire qu'il y
aurait à ce moment-là préméditation
change c'est pour ça que c'est important
ça passe de meurtre assassinat donc une
peine encore plus lourde
et donc si l'après-midi le geste là le
juge va très rapidement le réinterroger
pour savoir depuis quand il avait cette
idée en tête voilà merci merci Michel
Marie merci d'avoir été avec du nouveau
détective merci à vous